the UK has made its Mark in Ukraine
giving rocket launchers tanks and
missiles
but it doesn't have an infinite Supply
and has its own defenses to think about
hollowed out by Decades of cuts pressure
is now growing on the government to
spend more in the wake of Russia's War
but a defense Source has told Sky News
the chancellor and the treasury are
playing Hardball saying despite
recognizing the threats and the pressure
they say there is no more money
The Source then warned if you do not
replace what you're giving away to
Ukraine then the Army cannot fight
arguably it cannot fight now even at a
very small scale at least not for more
than a few days a former British head of
NATO said Rishi sunak needs to wake up
to the fact he is now a wartime prime
minister that means that we need to
spend more on defense we need to build
our capabilities and we must make sure
politically as well as militarily that
we're taking this threat very very
seriously
yet a refresh of the UK's defense policy
which is meant to frame the prime
minister's spending plans may be delayed
until after the budget far away from
Whitehall there's still confidence in Mr
sunac here in Kiev what message does it
send to Vladimir Putin if key supporters
of Ukraine key allies do not choose to
increase their defense spending in line
with the threat is
the UK's status as a key partner to
Ukraine and as a leading member of the
NATO alliance relies on it have
incredible armed forces and that could
require investment on top of what's
already been planned if as claimed the
Army in particular is at risk of
breaking
the government declined to comment on
speculation about the budget but a
spokesperson said defense had already
received extra funding since 2020 money
the Prime Minister had protected to
ensure his Armed Forces remain among the
best in the world pictured visiting
Ukrainian troops in the UK Mr sunac May
well need to go much further if he wants
the military to stay that way debraham
Sky News Keith